Plato argued that beyond our imperfect world...
...was a perfect unchanging world of Forms.
Forms are the ideal versions of the things and concepts...
...we see around us.
They serve as a sort of instruction manual to our own world.
Floating around the world of Forms is the ideal tree,...
...and the ideal YouTube channel, and even the ideal justice or ideal love.
Our own reality is comprised of imperfect copies of ideal Forms.
Plato argued that philosophers should strive to contemplate...
...and understand these perfect Forms...
...so that they may better navigate our misleading reality.
While it may seem silly, the disconnect between the world as it appears...
...and the greater truth behind it...
...is one of philosophy's most vexing problems.
It's been the subject of thousands of pages by theologians,...
...philosophers and screenwriters alike.
It raises questions like should we trust our senses...
...to come to the truth or our own reason?
For Plato, the answer is reason.
It alone provides us with at least the potential...
...to contemplate the Forms.